rebecca bonsoir soir on l'entend du
métro brièvement avant la pause oui le
nom des rues oui une chanteuse
américaine bon c'est très bon une
chanteuse américaine qui exercent une
ronde de fascination depuis ses débuts à
peu près quatre ans pour toutes sortes
de raisons c'est un personnage qui s'est
créée c'est la fille d'un millionnaire
que alors complètement raté son premier
passage de la ville à bienne lance un
troisième album intitulé ni moule et
c'est le meilleur des trois c'est celui
qui m'a convaincu on est dans la lune de
miel finalement et c'est son meilleur on
écoute du coup
[Musique]
m
cher
mais pas m
c'est très bon vous balancer ses pensées
non mais c'est je me suis un bon j'aime
ça je vais je sais pas parce que tout ce
qui m'énerve est tellement ivre à
présent il ya toujours ce détachement on
l'imaginait alanguie en train de boire
un verre de champagne sur un piano à
quelque part il ya les moins maniéré
qu'avant elle est toujours boudeuse mais
l'onirisme oui à tout à fait l'amour est
un peu boudeuse mais l'onirisme qui est
dans cet album là ils sont sur écoute ce
tôt le matin et tard le soir on est
comme dans un état second et elle est
devenue très habile avec les textes elle
l'a juste assez de recul juste à cette
conscience de soi pour nous vraiment
captivé avec ces histoires de trahison
de luxure et d'amour tourmentées donc
vous recommander chaudement
les moules surtout si vous aimez le
singel nomme les vieux les endroits ce
voyage une carte postale très bien et
plus et baby oui on connaît bien les
babys ce trio acadien qui a lancé un
premier album l'année dernière elles ont
fait beaucoup beaucoup de spectacles en
europe et là il ya un tiers des
libévilles vivianne roy et qui était
présent vivianne roy qui a décidé
est-ce qu'on arrête de télé jean ok on
la souris pourraient qui décide donc de
faire un album solo sous un pseudonyme
laurent sauvage et surprise
contrairement au rugby c'est en français
mais tout ça
[Musique]
non
moi j'aime vraiment ça je trouve que ça
coule de source et un mini album
seulement ça s'appelle americana
submarine il devrait avoir un premier
album complet en début d'année c'est
plus ces cinq courtes chanson sur le
déracinement l'errance avait écrit sont
en tournée parce qu'elle aurait beaucoup
de tournées et c'est plus plus
électrique bois abrasif que l'airé bevis
très très prometteur très accrocheur
également bon ben c'est une belle
semaine mais c'est une très belle solo
et puis on va se laisser avec la grande
sophie est ce que vous connaissez c'est
une chanteuse française que donc je
pense que vous allez vous devriez aimer
parce que ça ressemble à du catherine
major alors voilà la grande scène un
jour je le vois là la grande sophie que
les zones soir de 6 music pour mieux
connaître parce qu'on joue constamment
ses chansons qu'il y ait dans un
septième album intitulé nos histoires et
on veut seul échec le premier extrait
maria iodine ans que je dont j'ignorais
l'existence et mariait new dina c'était
la pianiste préféré de staline bien
malgré elle parce que c'était une
opposante au régime stade et nous vous
pouvez écouter l'album toute la semaine
gratuitement sur ici musique point ca
merci rebecca week end en week end
qu'ils soient
six ans
[Musique]
monsieur
non je ne suis pas non je ne suis pas
non je ne suis pas non je suis pas